yo man bullet cat podcast special guest
trench mob here
yo yo yo all y'all uh introduce
yourselves individually
you first me first jr007 man aka james
bond jr
it's tmb samuel jackson damiel jackson
legito let's keep money man shout out my
son keep penny and i like big girls over
300.
so you like fat [ __ ] man don't even
give me something
are you saying that because love is too
difficult okay okay listen correct
so you love him listen brother
well let's just start off with this
because i some people say that like it's
because it's funny but you actually hey
look
you're genuine that's why i'm not even
like i know you possibly can i know
you're supposed to get somebody
like actual eye contact when you having
a serious conversation but i gotta
it's so serious i gotta look away from
you it's like can you look at the camera
i just gotta
so you're into the the bb dubs huh
what's the heaviest um queen you've uh
poached i mean i won't oh no
cause like i got my nights i didn't poke
a lot of big things drunk you see
me so it's like when you wake up i can't
really remember the size but i just know
they was
the right size you ever you ever like
have a chick
like so so fat that you had to like lift
her sh
her like her left leg you know they got
that little boy you know they got the
little
the pupa the little the [ __ ] pouch
you know you know you see a fat [ __ ]
wearing leggings when i like
you know there's the pouch over the
price you ever have to lift that up
no like when i'm facing that i need to
make like when i'm facking the big girl
my big girl got to come correct like i
don't i'm not just out here like okay i
want
any big girl right okay i'm not just in
you got to be here she got to be like
you know she got had class like not too
much but she got to have like
certain things like you got to be able
to lift that up yourself
oh so she lifts the pouch you got to
have you got to you know
i haven't participated in such
activities
i'm good i'm married shout out to my
wife but i've been always curious
because i
i'm like how does that work it's a lot
to move around and
and then like when she lets go of it
does it like like
hits your dick and your dick falls out
cause the i don't know man
all i can really say is look dunk x
drink a little liquor
get that big girl in that room and see
what happens joe like
[ __ ] you just can't be thinking about it
too much or you gonna fumble
so you do the ecstasy and then you get
the fat chick you can do it with her
it's an exercise because you know x is
supposed to make you skinny so it's like
you can't just say you completely be
wrong so let me ask you something so
when you like
hit a [ __ ] you'll be like come and do
some cardio see look no no no
like you know like this could be guys
like my vibes
like any big girl like okay do you buy
cheeseburgers
see you gotta make sure they eat yeah
make sure they get home you gotta make
sure
okay so lizzo's somebody who you you
know obviously you would see like i like
that because you know like i ain't
saying like i'm trying to fact that
what i'm saying they're like i like that
because like i could tell she she one of
them big girls who
keep herself smelling good i like though
but is that is that like um
kind of the prototype of the type of
woman that you're into as far as like
shape wise
no no is she is she on the heavier side
i play around with like okay you won't
see me out here dang the big girl
oh wow
this guy is crazy anyway well welcome
fellas hey so quick
like first of all do you guys hear this
a lot like you guys give me
la vibes you guys are from chicago but
like when i first heard y'all's music it
just reminded me of some like
young la [ __ ] really is that we feel
like we begin like some comparisons
there's a microphone you're gonna have
to talk about i think we get i think
yeah they'd be giving us some of that
[ __ ]
like they'd be trying to not compare us
but like you know since like we a group
ain't really too many groups so they
kind of like shoreline yeah
like it's always a little like filming
so in a sense
well
[Music]
right right how did everybody meet [ __ ]
you got talking to the mic bro let him
roll his his back
yeah you guys can i'm just talking to
this one [ __ ] so [ __ ] this [ __ ] go like
way back
oh we we got another um rp sosa
he no longer with us but like we we all
been brothers really since like before
the music and really my homie right here
jr he started rapping with my big bro
sosa
and [ __ ] they really just like kicked
the whole [ __ ] off and then like little
by little everybody like started coming
together piecing up
you know it gives me some real uh
you know like when i was a kid we had
wu-tang clan because everybody in
wu-tang was was doing their solo [ __ ]
too i feel like you guys are a bunch of
dope solo artists on you in your own
right
come together yeah yeah everybody got
like their own look i think they go back
to the whole
like the cali thing like before before
anybody had moved out here everybody was
like
it was a more it was a more different
sound and then i think when you got when
we got out here
it we kind of like were around that
environment so this the music started
changing a little bit you know
it's a different we still have our own
our own sound
that we could always do but we just kind
of just where you at
right so coming out of chicago because
chicago we know chicago to be like
there's you know the kanye's and commons
and
you know chances and then on the other
side there's there's the dirks and the
king vaughn's and the
and the chief keefs and all that um it's
a very eclectic
music city for hip hop like what y'all
grow up listening to
like what really like influenced you
like your guys [ __ ]
i ain't gonna lie my favorite rapper
chief
my favorite rapper see man it's [ __ ]
up over here in my head
he was gonna say lizzy i'm riding around
like that chicago drill wave came later
though like at least at least for me
like i was about probably like
15 i don't know exact age 15 16 probably
oh
my [ __ ] she was listening right now i'm
saying when i'm saying what
inspired me like back when i was like
probably like 10 years old i'm listening
like 50 cent like i was listening to you
yeah not a g anyway it was crazy he
wasn't [ __ ] with eminem
nah nah i felt like that was like you
had like a poster on the wall
not are you white no i'm hispanic i'm
puerto rican oh yeah clarify that family
well you just well you just try to get
off the m m joke no yeah he's just
trying to this is everybody
so white but you know my mother's white
my father is puerto rican
okay it's mostly you know and i'm just
black as hell like i ain't got [ __ ]
like nothing else you're asian nothing
no no he's not asian
everybody just come up with their own
type of thing you look like you could be
related to stupid young i ain't gonna
lie
nah he shout
my mom was born in mexico my pop's board
of columbia oh [ __ ] okay so you got all
the plugs
everybody just kind of come up with
their own type of idea like they
this man is asian like it don't make no
sense but that's just what everybody
want to make up on the internet
what about you bro what are you man yo
chicago i heard chicago is like the only
city on the east coast so you could get
some real mexican food
yeah i i ain't going live bro
it's a couple spots out here that i
didn't [ __ ] with but i i don't know why
i feel like
nobody got better mexican friends every
chicago every time i'm on the east coast
the [ __ ] is trash everyone's like
chicago's fire hey you in chicago
go to taco so i'm [ __ ] diverse in
your heart
yeah it was crazy it's been a pretty um
it's crazy because you guys uh i feel
like are bringing the energy you know
out of that side of the the country that
you know i really don't think we've seen
until since like maybe asap mob
i appreciate that on some collective
[ __ ] you know
you feel me i feel like it's a little
chat that's how i look at too like so
when you look at chicago like you are
just ottoman like me yeah you got your
kanye's chances and [ __ ] but like
like the generation right now they just
they think it's like dirk and vaughn and
yeah
and that's why i listen to it personally
you feel me but like like you was
mentioning when i was a shorty
are you still you feel me i see you got
the little poster in the show
all that like i used to you know how
[ __ ] used to be like oh i know
what real music is and [ __ ]
like yeah yeah real hip-hop yeah yeah
you feel me but i feel like we got like
our own little drip with the sound so
it's not like
it's not the like same thing you're
hearing out of chicago but the sun just
like you know it's different like yeah
you got its own little
on the sauce what was the first time you
guys like caught a wave where you were
like oh [ __ ]
like we got something special going on
here was it like a like like what song
was it who song was it like what
happened
was him in our big bro uh they had two
everything right
yeah ain't gonna laugh bro that [ __ ]
really quick everybody started with me
at social
media yeah it was like a duo and he
brought him
before you feel me and like it's a lot
of other people in our group
that got talent too you feel me but this
is just a group for right now when
is everybody around the same age uh
i think i'm the youngest can i say
something look we cannot say ages on
here i got
cougar big girl i got big girls who are
cougars we need to stop this
we need to we need to skip the age
question folks like he's like 15 and a
half i ain't passionate
yeah what's the oldest what's the oldest
[ __ ] you slept with bro
yo crazy
oh no joe i'm saying though we might
sneak them to the 30s joe
damn man you just made me feel old as
[ __ ]
i'm 34. who yo who was up here oh and
ellie choppa said he slept with like a
49 year old lady
oh man chop come on man i was like
i was like bro she's a child molester
because he's [ __ ] 16.
well he was at the time that she don't
know about none of that [ __ ] i'm still a
virgin
god bless you man shout out my boy
bro you keep dipping your fingers in the
ass straight like they belong there
that's what she said for people who
don't know
uh these guys took down some edibles
seconds before the interview started
yes so whenever they start to kick in
y'all just like them
i said eat it be
recently you know i feel like every
group is broken up you know the ybn kids
broke up
uh you know there's always you know a
shoreline there's always
something going on how do you guys avoid
that same fate
when it comes just you feel me being
brothers for like
and this this what we was just talking
about the other day for like i feel like
when peop when they be breaking up
they're not really breaking up like
sometimes it'd be eagles and [ __ ] you
know it's a lot of ego [ __ ]
yeah so like so like for example like we
we got group projects and [ __ ] but we
[ __ ] with bro like we should we even
if he got his own he got his own solo
[ __ ] coming and we ain't no hating [ __ ]
you feel me like
right we pushing bro you feel me so yeah
no look i already wrote we already solo
artists
no for sure but we still got the trench
pop signaling so yeah i think
we already broken up we already broken
up but every tuesday
you feel me depending on what day it is
we come back together it's trench mouth
you feel me and we drop a transmit but
it's on tuesday
i think i think the dynamic it changed
when like
like he said like he started they
started um junior started
with sosa originally like this is when
it first started
whenever i don't remember the exact date
but it started with them they were going
nuts like they were going crazy
then things happen you know then they
brought in
they brought in spaz he started going
crazy then me
then key money i think we all at one
point were saying batman what is the
point
he locked up right now the whole point
is like at one point everybody was solo
artist
okay so like we already know that we was
doing this on our own anyway so now this
the group
like dynamic and like just survive it's
like we all are pushing to the same goal
now so we just doing it together now
but at the end of the day we all know
that we could do it it's either way like
it's like is
is it also a label situation or are you
guys all just just dropping [ __ ]
independently
running the empire play yeah we got a
little partnership
shout out to empardo indeed um so every
tuesday there's music coming out
this year yeah pretty much pretty much
oh yeah we're going to travel
pretty much yeah 2021 every every year
right that's a lot i mean that's a lot
of [ __ ] that's 52 weeks bro
[ __ ] we got we know we could do it wait
wait he said every tuesday
no every two tuesday night every other
tuesday oh okay that makes a little okay
let's do it hold on slow down everybody
i just knew we could do it
at this table and so much work it's just
like [ __ ]
like yeah everybody got at least like 15
20s
at least a minimum like 15 20 songs
already like i got over two
hundred songs all right got like three
hours right here hey
oh i saw the guy you go to sleep wake
back up in the studio this [ __ ] still
freestyling the [ __ ] in the mic
like i'm telling you like he do it all
he records himself and everybody oh [ __ ]
you like you like russ he's still a
[ __ ] though he likes the utility tool
like
what's the little thing called they got
all the pocket knife you know yeah i'm
gonna learn how to make pieces yeah so
we ain't gotta ask nobody for [ __ ]
hey amen that's the way to move it's
crazy you know
lately it feels like artists have become
targets and uh you know
when people passing away or getting shot
or robbed whatever like
how do you guys like have you guys
switch up the way you move around
does it stay dangerous stay on point
stay focused and surround yourself about
the right [ __ ] at all times
like
don't hang on a lot of times a lot of
times that be
other like you already know how to you
know what i mean like you already know
how to move
so like that be stuff that's not and i
feel like rappers
aren't targeted as far as like they they
make it seem like they targets to
anybody you know right they're
already been targets before the fame you
know what i mean well i feel like also
too it's like staying out the way
no the jail stuff yeah but i'm talking
about his father try to be too tough man
you could be trying to be too tough it
don't matter even if you got your gun on
before you could die with that [ __ ]
you know just stop trying to be tough
cause it'd be the goofies nowadays who
will kill you too like a [ __ ]
you never expected
look at you you let him do it to you
yeah
be humble you know keep it on you know
but
be humble don't go looking for that you
think to also just bring in that energy
you know like like because i feel like
when you bring that energy whether it's
through social media or whatever
it's almost like people like they then
then they look at that like oh now i
gotta check his temperature that's what
he's on
that's why you just gotta stay on point
like you just gotta be
ready for that [ __ ] like me like even if
a [ __ ]
approached me with like great vibes i'm
still always expecting that
right right right right it's just like
always [ __ ]
i'm in the interview hey shout out my
boy smiles too hey yeah
shout out smiles i'm an interview
i'm an interview but but hey shout out
my boy smiles you feel me i got my boy
smiles you know
he's another upcoming artist on chicago
no he ain't a weak rapper he got
he got amazon his videos too yeah smiles
back though
oh damn shout out to smiles for show
[ __ ] how to rap something on the phone
bro
um so what's like
2020 well first of all 2020 i feel like
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] up i'm sure you all
had
live shows and all kinds of [ __ ] playing
like preach yeah
fans bro how much you guys miss out on a
lot of bread
because of the pandemic on when it comes
to like yeah like i'm sure there were
some tours
or something like yeah like i'm sure we
could make more we didn't i'm
everybody's still good but i think 2020
here that pandemic
just got in the way of a lot of stuff
like right shout out to coronavirus
though a lot
you have oh y'all had it
a lot of my friends well this is scammy
l jackson so you know we already know
what that is
yeah that's the name i was looking for
we're gonna say nothing else he had a
memory but yeah not yo shout out to
everybody who's been taking advantage of
the situation
and uh you know doing so uh tastefully
so it's not too obvious
yeah there's been some real idiotic [ __ ]
going on in there i heard nice taking
out cars
stupid you saw the dude who made a whole
song and got a
yeah that's a that cloud [ __ ] is a hell
of a drug it's a drug
korean addiction it's a drug i don't
want that
yeah it's a comic-con family that's a
drug
um talk about you know because obviously
uh one of the biggest losses that we've
had in a long time was was vaughn
you know getting murdered and and you
know he was one of the biggest dudes out
of your city uh what was the impact of
his loss to chicago
rp vomit yeah i i [ __ ] with his music
sorry so it's like when i
like it's crazy like my little bro i
live with he like it's like seven or
eight in the morning for this [ __ ]
knocking on my door i'm
like i wake up mad like bro what the
[ __ ] like you feel me
all right what you knocking on my dirt
bike vaughn just died um damn
i like woke right up i'm like what the
[ __ ] like
if loki felt like a l4 like if i knew
the [ __ ] but you feel me but i don't
know
right right right you feel me that's
that [ __ ] was crazy felt that she had a
big impact i think
[ __ ] yeah no it was crazy yeah i feel
like just the whole situation it was
like
just [ __ ] up man we saw what happened
the video okay hit the internet i'm like
damn man
you know nobody got to see that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying uh any of the ogs
out of chicago like [ __ ] with y'all like
you guys get any of the co-signs from
any of the big
any anybody out of out of the city
that's that's you know considered a og
i don't really know much oh geez
i don't know if you know bodil mm-hmm
a lot of people know yeah i feel like
there's like so much
history y'all know who crucial conflict
is i heard of it
i just gotta ask i'm just i'm just i'm
just checking to see how old i am
i'm just old it's all guys no we
probably supposed to know about it what
about do or die come on
don't do or die yeah
i'm gonna just say yeah look
look this might not make sense to this
look we get hot every day we know these
things but we just can't put up
on them well you guys did eat edibles
recently like yeah that too
i don't get high every day that's dumb
look though not even that though but
like
no he just don't want to show y'all
so it's kicked in officially yeah i
ain't gonna like y'all said the
interview about time the interview ended
it was gonna you feel
me kick in somebody else
hey let's see that we hey let's see
let's see that weed you had get that uh
that
that uh that full sandbag the one that
has the uh
it's got the that money man [ __ ] in it
the epidemic no other one the other one
it's in the other room
oh my god you don't want me to fry you
that's not what that's going to consist
of you don't want
[Music]
damn this guy said you look like a
salamander with dreads
could we not get that i'm a fry's ass
anything i don't do that i'm not i know
i know hey this that [ __ ] right here
again
that's turtle pie this right here hey
wrote this up he's
too high to roll right now my my fingers
be shaking and [ __ ]
when i'm too high my fingers be shaking
and [ __ ] every time i eat an edible i'll
be wanting to grind my teeth
damn i barely can see you i'm just
enjoying it
question what is the uh the craziest
groupie experience that y'all have ever
had
there's so many i don't think it really
been like i feel like yeah
like we kind of like still like coming
you guys are still on the come up so
ain't nothing ain't nothing crazy has
happened it's like
they like when we watch this right up in
here dudes i ain't you that one you feel
me so it'd be like this little [ __ ] or
maybe a picture here and there but it
ain't really
ain't been no like we i'm talking about
you know because sometimes
groupies are men too well go ahead no
no no no no i don't mean i don't mean
like they ain't trying to [ __ ] y'all but
you know what i mean
no yeah it's shout out to him bro
because you feel me that's what's up bro
yeah
no i ain't gonna lie
i didn't know he was talking about that
type of [ __ ] but like it'd be weird [ __ ]
like
like [ __ ] be asking for our
addresses and how we get our hair cut
and [ __ ] like
really it'd be limited just hitting my
dm i'm talking about uh
when you when you go to the barber what
are you asking for so you know what i
i've been seeing the message but i had
told him about it
but i was bored so i told him zero all
around
top and bottom oh baby [ __ ] like that
just shave your head he said i bet
oh you said you had a story oh yeah so
so look when i was like when it was
early
first popping off me and sosa that's
around like like the two of everything
type of time you feel me we i used to go
to these parties and [ __ ] on
like a little village like like on the
south side whatever like little mexico
bill
and so at one of them i was i was
performing like a little song or
whatever right but there was no stage
you feel me i'm just in a party whatever
i should look he's like ghetto without i
shouldn't have been doing that [ __ ] but
but so so so i'm performing or whatever
and it's this
this girl come up come up in my ear with
like this
cuban accent or whatever she she kissed
me and like she
she came in my face but like but i don't
give a [ __ ] about none of that
whoa what the [ __ ] i i push her back i'm
not the same that
she she come back on me i'm curry hey
get this [ __ ] off me
right my boy curry he fleeing [ __ ]
across the room
well that's okay well you know shout out
to kirby you know what i mean
shout out shout out my boy curio that
so she did not get uh get get any more
attention from you the rest of night no
that's where that ended um
[Music]
hey so look so we're doing something
with empire where
we animate the story that we're about to
tell
so imagine you guys are going to tell
the story and it's going to turn into a
cartoon
damn [ __ ] the highest
you guys have ever been in your entire
life
yesterday the highest like give me the
details the crate like where were you
where
were you at what did you see were you
tripping balls the highest y'all ever
been in your life off
of anything i ain't gonna lie
you gotta grab the mic i didn't been
high off a lot of ecstasy before but
that's
that's a different ball game that's
that's for real demons we got problems
but
the hottest time for a lot it's a funny
story i used to get my homie like when i
first met
my homie just locked up khalif for my
home he's doing 10 right now but that
was like the first [ __ ] i met right i
was my homie
and then what's it called i was always
you feel me
like my granny gave me like 10 15 bucks
like you feel me every day while i was
you feel me in school you feel me
hooping and [ __ ]
so i take my 10 or 15 and i always you
feel me by look because you know back in
the day [ __ ] were smoking like
point fives a little bit
right so i'll just always spark up my
homies basically like matching and [ __ ]
but like for a while i wasn't getting
high bro like
i wasn't i don't know i wasn't inhaling
the wii right so so i finally this one
day bro i see my homie heat
like double hit that [ __ ] so i'm like
let me see what's up with the
little double hit so that they fall for
i was blasted on my mind so i'm
laying on the stairs i'm folded out
shorty we was low-key like young as hell
i'm like oh like
he look he had his bike i didn't have my
bike he walked me home from
damn like then i get to the crib for you
know them you know shout out to them lil
we need a sponsorship what's them uh you
know them polar bear icy pops
[Music]
killed like the whole box blue and red
was the best one you had brain for you
i don't know what i have for but i was
hiding a [ __ ] like six of them [ __ ]
knocked out on the couch
[ __ ] yo have to stop the bootleg podcast
real quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the drawls man
the boxer briefs are so fire they're so
soft
they feel great on your ass your nuts
whatever you're into
you know what i'm saying whatever you
got they'll cover them up real real
comfortably
and ladies you know you can wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know
one of the licenses they just got that i
love uh are the naruto socks they just
got the naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
rick flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg kev
at oddssoxoficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it
anybody else got a high story what about
you man did you get high and sleep with
the bbw or anything i'm saying though
like it's over like
500 just like the craziest time story so
it's like hard to like
grab a second find the best one yeah
like i ain't gonna lie to you it's like
i want to show you the world right now
but it's
hard it's like damn crazy
look they don't like man you would just
have to damn
be there yeah i'll be high like that's
just what need to be known
it'd be [ __ ] up i'm pretty damn there
pretty hard right now
this might be this might be the one i
might get to tell about this make us a
cartoon or some [ __ ]
yo you guys you guys had an edible and
you're just [ __ ] melting in your
chairs right yeah like that's not that's
what i'm saying like i don't have an
actual like i don't think i can put in a
cartoon because i really don't be
remembering like
like yesterday i was [ __ ] trying to
make it i don't even know
oh no i don't know the [ __ ] word but
like
you gotta tell the story that [ __ ] just
got imma have him
like some type of funny [ __ ] this is so
funny for you i don't even really know
bro he keeping real common collective
but behind all the cameras i'm saying
like this one of the funniest
[ __ ] i know so we'll be on
something like family guy
you know simpson's type of cartoon [ __ ]
and i'm having him are you like you
you strike me as quagmire oh yeah he's
he's requested
a window and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
[Music]
you guys big family guy uh watchers nah
i like him
when i was younger i ain't really i
watched it like i guess you say that
because it was on
everybody was talking about it back like
when we were younger but yeah back in
the day
south park i like something i mean watch
that [ __ ] though now back in the day i
didn't understand they jokes because
some of these jokes over your head
you're gonna be older yeah so when you
were shorter you like
your pops laughing and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
yeah i ain't even funny i didn't really
think it was that funny i watched it but
i ain't no they'd be having some good
episodes i like the little popsicle dude
funny but that's really it yo would
y'all be binge watching
[ __ ] in the last year i gotta watch
man free joe exotic man a year a year
later we're still ringing off
freeze man i don't even get mad [ __ ]
carol baskin
on what bro all their mother you didn't
watch tiger no i i watched like
like like he had all these little young
husbands that he that he was getting
hooked on meth
oh no you know what i've seen nah sorry
i've seen the video
i want y'all to hear this clear now you
know i didn't watch that [ __ ] cuz that's
some nut [ __ ] like
you would never catch me i don't know he
was busy watching [ __ ] southpaw i'm
watching some stupid [ __ ] they talking
about
the meth smoking i don't even know what
the [ __ ] they think this guy is
two husbands he's a gay dude with two
husbands and tigers
he just had an accent so funny folk bro
all i've seen is all i seen is joe
exotic was is the dude with the blondes
he looked like dog the bounty hunter he
was smoking that crystal meth yeah
with shitholes they say all it takes is
one hit
and you're done oh trust me i don't
wanna do that
i got all my all my uncles are all
messed out no teeth like it's a bad
thing damn that [ __ ] baby
selling the clothes [ __ ] man oh man my
uncle used to come to my crib when i was
little
nah but yeah but he would just come into
my
like like like he's we lived in an area
called sunny slope this will be
tripped out on meth and he thought he
had bugs in his skin
i remember walking in on the bathroom
and this [ __ ] was picking his
face
with a with tweezers bleeding out of his
face damn
hold on that's that meth [ __ ]
i don't even wanna talk about that hey
you guys watch snowfall
hell yeah damn you know what who was
just telling me to watch that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] oh no tyler man was just
telling this [ __ ] that [ __ ] is hard
i was watching the snow will you watch
snowfall yeah yeah what's it about
though
it's about it's about the crack crack
epidemic in l.a in the 80s it's pretty
much freeway ricky ross is
loose it's amazing it's a movie it's
like a movie but joe
if you saw it tell me why when uh
franklin's girlfriend the pretty young
girl she hits the crack pipe right
and she just falls out like yeah
[Applause]
she was having the time my life she was
[ __ ] up though but she was
bro but i'm saying crap crack got to be
so crazy because if you're
if you do all this wild [ __ ] it got to
be like better than
sex
and she was just like talking y'all seen
that video the crackhead she knocking on
the
door he telling her like yeah you gotta
go she's like
that's how i mean she caught in his ass
this guy's been rolling this thing for
[ __ ] 10 minutes he's been breaking
that [ __ ] down for 30.
he's high man oh he said he was high
look look i really should be the one bro
this big ass like
i should be the one there's one right
there but that's a lot higher that's a
little angled at me you feel me it's a
little like get him
that was like a he's a cool guy
yo
but it is cool light ain't that bad just
give a little
bling to the interview you feel me a
little bit like it make a [ __ ]
all right it's doing instagram affection
[ __ ]
you guys are you guys see all right
that's why my head like i don't be
asleep the whole time i just end up
falling asleep bro i'll be like this
it'd be like the lights are
[ __ ] yeah you guys are high for
sure man
oh man yeah we haven't yet feeling good
oh no you're not yourself when you're
hungry so think about it if we ate
you hear me we probably give you the
best of us so every
who who's living in la now is everybody
yeah i'll be out here now no
[ __ ] we used to all live we used to all
live you like you don't like talking
into the mic
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah shout out
so everyone's out here now no no it's
just like like we were saying earlier
this is like a lovely filming bring the
family together go work in the studio
like la is a you know shut the [ __ ] down
chicago is it like more open like yeah
we just make it look open we make it
look open
they get busted they'll wear masks
everywhere yeah no but i i mean like can
y'all eat inside of a restaurant chicago
yeah they just did that [ __ ] probably
what like two or three months ago that's
it
i don't think they posted out here
outside you still gotta wear masks
everywhere though i mean you know
there's some places you don't have to
wear masks anymore so nobody in trench
mob
at this table has caught the coronavirus
officially i think i did
not officially that's impressive
[Music]
well he got it now oh you you carter
ronan
waukeesha no i actually just got a
negative test yesterday i'm good but now
i had the ronin in like june i couldn't
smell [ __ ]
but you ain't getting like your major
effects though like i was just like how
was that shiva
i just couldn't smell um and i probably
had a
flu or some
you're a real conspiracy theorist huh
that's what [ __ ] said they gave you
that
meditation you gotta drink a lot drink a
lot of water meditate and ginger
i just started the first time i
meditated my mama pissed me off it was
my first time
ever oh my grandma like for real for
real my first time meditating ever i'm
meditating
if i got like one minute left she coming
down what the [ __ ] you doing
i'm proud of the guy it's my first time
ever trying to [ __ ]
she coming at me eternal life what the
[ __ ]
how deep in were you like probably the
guy it was like a minute
i didn't want to like keep knowing her
she like so you can't [ __ ] hit me you
know i'm almost get to take it
like hey when you told your mom your mom
when you told your mom you were
meditating did she laugh at you
oh i i was like when i first like when
she came
in and like blew blew me and i finally
said whoa
okay no no no no no no wait wait no
no no chicago i know i know okay okay
y'all gonna put me on to this no no
chicago slaying like
like like like me i was like okay she
pissed you off okay okay i'll be i'm
just saying
what the [ __ ] is going on in chicago
jesus christ
he said my mom came in my room and blew
me
i just thought about it the way he
thought about it like now it's stuck in
my head like that like
[ __ ] like like like if something makes
you mad like damn i should blew the hell
out of me feel me
you know i'm saying the show so if like
if he made you mad you'd be like man you
blew me bro yeah hell yeah
i ain't gonna fly yeah you just blew me
you you making it like a homo ass wave
folks
i don't want to say yeah but like hey
i'm just saying
[Music]
levine like misses a shot at the end of
a bulls game you'll be like man zach
levine blew me last night bro
hell yeah if i'm on fanduel yeah talk to
him [ __ ] yeah
hey if you know you know that's what we
gonna say bro y'all know what we talking
about y'all know what he's saying so
oh yeah yeah he's been going nuts
all-star
hey he tapping with y'all he said is
that your people or whatever
yeah no he just giving he's good right
he's cool finally i [ __ ] with him
i thought he was like a bad a good stats
bad team type of guy but this year he's
you know
yeah i know i mean i still think i mean
bro now the bulls still aren't good i
mean i still think he's not a mediocre
ass team like
[Music]
yeah won't be a team but you know you
got to have your favorite team you
should
well who's the other team bring derose
back to the bulls man i'm not going to
lie to y'all like let me just say this
why we why we on this subject i'm not
rooting for no weak ass team if they're
a losing team i'm not rooting for them i
don't know you want them to lose you get
the draft
aka he has lebron james penis in his
mouth aka he has lebron
i love the bulls i got lebron's nuts in
my mouth too so absolutely lebron go
lakers let's win this money huh
simple as that like you still got that
bet from left yeah let's go with lebron
hey i want to say one thing man
you're going to be rich pause let's go
lebron i had to throw a pause in cause i
said i had lebron's nuts in my mouth 30
seconds ago
it was it was a very late pause but go
ahead what were we going to say man
damn i'm stuck stuck
when the edibles kick in man look
hey yeah yeah look come with the next
question man
come with the next question
all right y'all do me a favor rank
y'all's top five
favorite top the top five chicago mcs
ever
[ __ ] rapper man all rapper then like
top five out of chicago do we got it
are we showing respect or no as far as
like do i have to like you give me like
if you don't do it
i don't really like how your music but i
mean he's technically
you don't like any of kanye's music
college
if you don't put them up there you kind
of bugging like well top five
top five in chicago you gotta i gotta
put you keep up that doesn't like
i ain't gonna rank them in the order but
you gotta put them up there if you [ __ ]
with chicago music
i'm [ __ ] with keith herbal
the dirk
i'm so old you gotta be wrong if you do
that
kanye you're a liar no but you gotta put
kanye up that he's
okay and probably as of right now
probably polo can i hey foreign
i only know that song that's the only
one i know except for is one more song
but it's not him rapping he's like a
robot
now that she likes stronger yeah that
[ __ ] that's only two songs
i focus i just i just ain't the
you know i just ain't my type of music
what's your five bro i don't i ain't
gonna say like top five mcdonald's i'm
saying my favorite rappers
okay your favorite of all time from
chicago like
uh ain't no order though dirk herb
uh chief keef young pappy
i listen to a lot of everything shout
out to everybody look
can we skip me because it's like it's
like it's like it's like
i don't even know who i want to put in
that like i think i think you're melted
bro
i'll melt it yeah never melt it we can
get that
we can get started
what the [ __ ] does that even mean i
don't know what the [ __ ]
have you guys ever listened to common in
your life this is just a random question
no no actually i ain't gonna lie i don't
know nobody goes in the car
they'll
his face
hey this is the guy from the tyler perry
movies is that oh that's tyler perry
yeah yeah
talk to the [ __ ] mic bro i'll
probably i'll probably be hearing some
comment with my pops
but i can't name one song about comment
though i ain't even gonna lie i think
i think he's too [ __ ] up as far as
like hey shout out i got like a real
serious flow low key like
i don't even know how much
this this is amazing this is my favorite
part of the interview the common
question
that [ __ ] is hilarious a lot of people
know like when you be asking them do
they know
i don't ask i've never asked anyone that
i just
i just i just had a feeling that this
would happen i think i think that would
be another like a segment i already
handled that
i know i know he he a big name though he
just asked that because
chicago and he's been in a lot of movies
though he like a concept
wait how old are you a rapper i'm sorry
are you all around the same i'm 20.
you're 20.
oh yeah well [ __ ] man
i was getting [ __ ] 20 years ago man
coming low-key
[Music]
he took ice cubes face off in a battle
i mean ice cube had beef and common put
a song out battling that man we could
have [ __ ] rap battles
nah bro i used to watch that [ __ ] come
and put it out you know what i called
the [ __ ] in you
and murdered ice cube and then i was
watching though ice cube
never mind let me stop that he's like
that's another guy in tyler perry movies
right who's right now i'm not going to
ask you i'll see you guys
i didn't see some raw battles though not
a battle battle like how y'all are used
to you know not in the youtube [ __ ] like
they were putting dis records out saying
that bro i'm saying like a rap battle
you talking about a rap battle yeah like
i'm talking about ice cube and comments
they drop records on each other
what's his favorite young jesus like
each other no that was actually a zulu
yeah that was crazy they were selling
this record what about twista
i don't know y'all listening to twitter
i grew up rocking beds to twist them man
shout out twister joe i don't listen to
him
oh listen to him no more though oh yeah
okay
okay
what does that make you move i [ __ ]
around hey keep penny off that
why do you think there's um two two
sides to the chicago music scene like
there's the chance the rapper type [ __ ]
vic menta that kind of stuff right
and then there's the other side the
drill [ __ ] the it's really just bro like
just to be real honest i was just two
type of people out here like
not yeah like i mean let me hit that man
you guys been
you know you could listen oh
yeah he offered it to me once but he's
been around
money don't get down like that relax
relax nah just forgot bro wasn't smoking
another one with us
you guys you guys ever consider
switching to papers
hey i was in jamaica that was there was
one of the papers man shout out much i'm
making money making people back home for
to make it like my second home it's the
first time you hit it too buddy i'm
flashing i've been there like one time
you don't like being high anyways
[ __ ] you ate edible
didn't you he's the one who asked for it
they just be talking i'm saying though
where'd you get them chocolate ones
hey can we get another one of those or
what i got you it's my homie that's why
i [ __ ] about chocolate
edibles chocolate edibles epidemic
oh yeah all right well look man this was
fun this is real fun
yeah i gotta put comment on the song now
comment come on shout out comment
hey look coming okay we ain't gonna
charge you that much either
and uh hey i'm doing no feature now you
know
did you guys are so tapped in out here
who's some of the la artist that you
guys
rock with that rock with y'all damn late
oh [ __ ] man i got some san bernardino
homies though
shout out j.i bands man san bernardino's
uh interesting place it is yeah it is
right
they're getting it in over there do you
know that is nico
i feel like you would know who every san
bernadino rapper is for some reason
are you sure oh no anyway well look
y'all uh
new music is out you guys just dropped
some [ __ ] right oh yeah shout out
santeezy too
shout out my boy elijah back he's a good
people we just
what we just released elijah banks shout
out elijah banks
yeah we just dropped like a little
completion look whatever yeah
that'd be hard well yeah why is he a
good dude man
you guys um you know saving your money
and [ __ ]
yeah we don't we talking to bro we we're
not thugging necessarily like even we
just you feel me
on our grind right now like yeah trying
to get to you friends
every dollar matter every dollar matters
we're gonna shut that [ __ ] up to the
ceiling there it is man uh
appreciate y'all for pulling up and um
that was interesting
you're [ __ ] high this guy's [ __ ] up
right
too [ __ ] yeah the day consists of just
keep
getting higher it's [ __ ] up feel me
it's [ __ ]
[Music]
that's how you spell it you know he's
just a goof fast
we gonna eat with the duck so he can get
high too
kevin with the kfo is there a cab with
his sibo
no i'm not getting it is this my rap
name
yeah okay with the case